en este vídeo vamos a mostrar que en un
paralelogramo los ángulos opuestos son
congruentes
es decir viendo el dibujo vamos a probar
que el ángulo de ave es congruente al bc
de osea que éste es congruente al
opuesto y que el ángulo abc es
congruente al cda osea que éste es
congruente al opuesto vale y para hacer
esto vamos a pensar a los segmentos del
paralelogramo no como segmentos sino
como rectas eso nos va a permitir pensar
en ciertas rectas paralelas y en
transversales en realidad sólo va a ser
un cierto cambio de perspectiva porque
una misma recta la vamos a poder ver
como como un elemento de una pareja de
rectas paralelas o bien como una
transversal déjame déjame mostrarte a
qué me refiero mira déjame marcar el
ángulo bcd en color rojo y este de acá
va observa que podemos pensar a ave y
hace de como un par de rectas paralelas
en donde se es una transversal entonces
este ángulo lo podemos pasar para acá a
qué me refiero con esto déjame ponerle
por aquí que se llama el punto me
refiero a que él
ángulo el ángulo de cb lo voy a poner
aquí el ángulo de c b es congruente al
ángulo c b
y le voy a poner aquí ángulo ángulo cb y
esto es porque son ángulos alternos
internos de este par de paralelas con
esta transversal vale entonces le voy a
poner aquí por ángulos porque son
ángulos alternos internos vale bueno
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es cambiar de
perspectiva ahora vamos a pensar abc
como una paralela de ade y ahora ave va
a ser nuestra transversal si lo hacemos
así entonces ahora este ángulo puede
pasar para acá porque porque estos son
ángulos correspondientes de esta pareja
de rectas paralelas con esta transversal
déjame apuntar eso el ángulo cb y el
ángulo el ángulo se ve
es congruente al ángulo al ángulo ve a
de de ave vale le voy a poner ángulo d
y esto de aquí es porque son ángulos
correspondientes por ángulos ángulos
correspondientes vale muy bien entonces
tenemos que el ángulo de cb este de acá
es congruente al cb y el cb es
comúnmente al de a b y entonces podemos
concluir que el ángulo de cb que es este
de aquí es congruente al de abel
entonces estos dos ángulos opuestos son
congruentes y vamos a hacer exactamente
lo mismo para probar que los otros dos
ángulos también son congruentes déjame
hacerlo con otro color creo que ya lo
puedo hacer un poco más rápido
entonces voy a marcar el ángulo cde en
color verde aquí voy a poner un punto
digamos
efe está sobre el segmento voy a alargar
un poquito más ahí está entonces ahora
este ángulo el c d
lo voy a poner aquí el ángulo c
d
es congruente al ángulo de a efe al
ángulo de a efe
esto de aquí es por ángulos alternos
internos ángulos alternos internos y
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es pensar a
de a abc como paralelas y abe como una
transversal de modo que este ángulo lo
podemos pasar acá porque son ángulos
correspondientes y así el ángulo de a
efe de a efe es congruente es congruente
al ángulo
de c y esto de aquí es porque son son
ángulos correspondientes
correspondientes vale si quieres lo
podemos marcar así doble para que se
entienda que no necesariamente son
iguales a los rojos bueno ya están con
otro color pero así se entiende todavía
más vale entonces ya tenemos que el adc
es congruente al de a efe y el de a efe
al abc y por lo tanto los ángulos a bc y
adc son congruentes y con esto ya
mostramos que si tenemos un
paralelogramo entonces los ángulos
opuestos cualquier par de ángulos
opuestos son congruentes